hey guys how are you so today's gonna be
just a very quick unboxing because I was
so excited about this and I've been
holding on to this for almost a week to
open for you guys this is the Star Wars
kylo Ren Disney infinity 3.0 figure and
if you guys are new here you probably
have no idea how obsessed I am with sort
of the toys to life and obsessed with
amiibo when I absolutely love the Lego
dimension series so the whole Disney
infinity is pretty new to me but this
here is my first-ever Disney infinity
character and I don't think I can be any
more excited than having kylo Ren be my
first please hold
how do I turn this off anyway let's uh
let's just let's open it up it's gonna
be really difficult hold on you you
might want to pause the video cuz things
are getting wild maybe we put this in
slo-mo this is fantastic you guys
haven't seen it I actually got a chance
to go and check out Skywalker Ranch not
too long ago we also went there and then
we also entered us Tree Light & Magic
and kind of got to see how they create
everything and especially going behind
the scenes and just seeing the history
of not only this franchise but other
movies and films that they've worked on
it was just absolutely incredible so you
wanna check that out I'll put a link in
the description there's also a wonderful
little lightsaber battle that I did move
myself at the end and then I threw this
and hit the wall anyway I'm gonna go
I just wanted to show you guys this
because a bunch of you who tweeted me at
the game award and said please do an
unboxing please do man boxing so here I
am I did it I've been waiting and now
kylo Ren is gonna go join the rest of
his friends downstairs here at Disney
and I'm extremely excited because I
haven't been here in a long time since
they have like all the Christmas
decorations and stuff up they also have
all of the Star Wars thing